you said that I could not invite Dwight
because he was not part of a couple and
because we didn't have enough wine
glasses Dwight brought glasses and a
person fine whatever you want just like
always whatever you want whatever I want
it's never whatever I want
I wanted to see stop and you wanted to
see Wicked what did we see we saw when I
said that I wanted to have kids and you
said that you wanted me to have a
vasectomy what did I do
when you said that you might want to
have kids and I wasn't so sure who the
second reversed and then when you said
you definitely didn't want to have kids
who want to reverse back step stop step
I did okay you have no idea the physical
toll the three vasectomies have a person
and I bought this condo to fill with
children I'm so sorry that I don't want
to bring kids into this screwed up World
okay but look if you want to have kids
then fine you win
kid
do you mean you wanna pick it
I hate my life
so can we come in
the criminal justice system the people
are represented by two separate but
equally important groups
the police who investigate the crimes
and the district attorneys who prosecute
the offenders these are their stories
he wrapped his belt around his own neck
it looks like a classic case of
auto-erotic asphyxiation yeah it looks
like everybody's tightening their belts
in this economy
the last time you saw the victim was he
happy last time I saw this John
he was he wasn't a victim if you know
what I'm talking about thank you no that
was just part I'm just getting into the
First Act that's the last of it oh
that's mine actually
um maybe put it back in the truck you
know staying you know I have some things
I need to do this weekend
I just remembered so
I'll just write back with you but you
want me to put it back in the truck I'll
be down in just a second
Holly
so um
I think I'm gonna go back with Daryl
okay
bye okay bye
foreign
what is this it's real simple
if you don't appreciate what we do then
give us back our basket maybe you should
leave
Mary should
maybe you should leave come on let's
leave but before we leave my wife friend
and I are gonna wait for our cabs on
your nice couches can you call us a cab
please I'm gonna oh sorry look my
clothes are so wet wet nice leather oh
my shoes are so muddy
all right here you go take it back
it's been opened yeah it was mine What's
missing
there's Turtles where's the turtles
where are the turtles come on guys get
out of here
okay where are they excuse me I have an
announcement to make we seem to be
missing a box of chocolate turtles with
pecans and we will not be leaving the
premises until we obtain them hand over
the turtles now
I ate them okay I ate the turtles
they're gone
we'll build you
foreign
this office will not be using any new
technology ever starting now that is not
correct Ryan thinks that technology is
the answer well guess what I just drove
my car into a lake is it what I drove my
car into a lake
Phyllis how are those mittens coming
because I would actually like to bring
them home and pack them and I'm leaving
for the day at four they're almost done
but my Knuckles are swelling a little
well power through the arthritis fellas
you can do it
is that it
um
um
no
no
it's a special guest
and I would like to invite to say in one
last goodbye
here he comes he's coming right again hi
everybody
it's ping and I'm here to say goodbye to
all you wonderful people thank you
everybody
you've been so wonderful we've had such
a quick
[Music]
I love you very much hey I'm gonna talk
to you for a second sure all right see
you right now
so I've been meaning to tell you I want
to take you out for lunch for your last
day
oh
what do you think tomorrow lunch you and
me okay
you're not leaving tomorrow
you're leaving today right
Maybe
wow so that's it huh just
four o'clock and you were gone for good
why am I so sad
am I doing the wrong thing
absolutely not
it's just that sometimes goodbyes are a
[ __ ]
t-shirt idea goodbye stink
okay all right so
James Halpert
you started with his company
as a fine young man you know what I
think we should do
I think we should just say the goodbyes
for tomorrow at lunch
oh
okay
and then tomorrow
I can tell you
what a great boss you turned out to be
best boss I ever had
oh shoot
that's my cab all right all right
listen Michael I really I did text Pam
but I know it's okay
just give her a hug all right
I'll see you tomorrow at lunch I am
looking forward to watch
and hearing about what a great Buzz
Light
you got it
brownies I'm taking two so I can parcel
them up and eat them at my leisure later
on much healthier you're taking two
yeah um but one of the mystery Toby
yeah why don't you send that to him in
Costa Rica
um I'm just gonna hand it to him right
now okay weirdo why is that why is that
weird she said she's gonna give it to
him right now I just felt like going to
you because they sit next to each other
yeah they used to
by works here again oh can you imagine
oh no oh
I don't know what you should probably
just Meander back there take a look see
if he's see if he's back dare I
you know what I'm going to For Old Times
Sake
great practical joke Jim can we go to
the annex
I'm like no God
no God please no no no
no
and now a man who deserves no
introduction
Michael Scott
thank you very much
thank you that was great
great job some great laughs
really
really went after my intelligence there
dozens of online IQ tests might prove
you wrong but
and my thing isn't
tiny it's average so
get your facts straight
um
so when I heard that there was going to
be a roast in my honor
I thought
you have a frog in my throat
um
I decided to jot down some quick
thoughts about you people
um
first up uh Phyllis again
um
foreign
[Music]